وصل رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شغل ميشال الى
كييف هل دوت السفارات مجددا من مظاهر
التاهب بالتزامن مع هذه القمه الاوروبيه
الاوكرانيه
مرحبا الحسينيه منذ حوالي ساعه من الان
دوت صافرات الانذار في الشرق وجنوبي وغرب
اوكرانيا على ما يبدو ان الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه حسب الان تغريده نشرها احد
المسؤولين العسكريين قد رصدت تحرك طائرات
مقاتله في الحدود الشماليه من جهه
المتاخمه لمدينه
الحدود البيلاروسيه لم نتاكد الى حد الان
ما ان كان تم استهداف او ستستهدف احد
المدن او المقاطعات الاوكرانيه هنا في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه شاهدنا تواجد امني
كثيف على كل الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه
قبل يومين فقط قالت انها تنتظر حراكا او
تحركا عسكريا روسيا الميدانيه على ما يبدو
ان موسكو بعثت برسائلها الان قبل ساعات من
انطلاق هذه القمه القمه الاوروبيه مع
اوكرانيا الاستثنائيه والرمزيه مثل ما قلت
عبد القادر يعني تابعنا في كلمه هذا وصول
لشغل ميشيل تعهد بدعم انضمام اوكرانيا الى
الاتحاد لكنه لم يقل ان ذلك سيكون من خلال
قمه اليوم في المقابل الرئيس زيلينسكي
يريد ان تكون قمه اليوم على ارض انطلاق
رسميه لبدء المفاوضاته الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي عموما من خلال معلوماتك
واتصالاتك المنتظر بشكل ملموس من قمه
اليوم
هي مثل ما سبق وقلنا هي قمه استثنائيه
ورمزيه هذا هو العنوان الاكبر الذي يمكن
ان نضعه لهذه القمه التي اول مره الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعقد قمه في دوله تخوض حرب جاريه
ودائره الان قبل قبل قبل رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي سبق وان تحدثت رئيسه المفوضيه
ارسل عندما كانت هنا وقالت اننا نحن هنا
في كييف لنرسل رساله الى اوكرانيا شعبا
وقياده ورساله اخرى الى موسكو الرساله
الاولى لاوكرانيا يريد الاوروبيون ان تكون
رساله دعم غير مشروط وغير منتهي عسكريا
وماديا الرساله الاخرى التي تحملها هذه
القمه الرمزيه لموسكو الا وهي تؤكد على
وحده الموقف الاوروبي بخصوص دعم اوكرانيا
في حربها التي بدات التي تقارب عام
وتنفي كل الجدل الذي كان حاصل مؤخرا حول
بعض الانقسامات
من من فيفري يعني وهي السنه السنه التي
اراد الاوروبيون ان تكون سنه رمزيه لارسال
رساله الى شكرا جزيلا لك من
العاصمه الاوكرانيه عبد القادر